so today I'm going to be showing you
guys the DJI spark it fits in the palm
of my hand and not only does it fit in
the palm of my hand but it will actually
take off and then land again in the palm
of my hand
[Music]
this tiny little palm-sized drone is
probably one of the coolest things that
I've seen in a really really long time
what I love most about this is it really
is a beginner throat if you've never
touched a drone before this is pretty
much the easiest thing that I've ever
seen it has front obstacle avoidance
sensors which is one thing that most
smaller drones don't have if you guys
are familiar with the Maverick there's
two modes there's an RC mode and there's
a Wi-Fi mode so on here this essentially
creates a hotspot you connect to the
hotspot on your phone here's the camera
it's a 1080p camera you can fly this for
about 15 to 16 minutes Mir which is
pretty a long time for something so
small so for a battery size comparison
here's the Maverick battery and here's
the smart battery look only what this is
you actually don't need to do anything
you don't need a controller you don't
need your phone it can be controlled
completely with gesture control I'm
going to try v gesture control without
syncing it to my phone and if you do the
palm takeoff and landing it's
recommended that you put the prop guards
on for safety reasons so they just clip
off just like that and they go
underneath of the propellers snap it on
that's it so to do the palm takeoff and
landing you need to turn it on and then
as soon as you see the lights start
flashing you then press it two times
it'll recognize your face and as it
starts taking off you can remove your
hand and that's it it just works okay Oh
[Music]
nope I'm going to Italy
yeah
Wow
Oh
much like the Mavic these are very
similar you just kind of push down and
pop them off i know polish is hideous
honest i'm sorry it was a mistake it's
got this cute little carrying case so
you can just pop them right in and be on
your way this is like the size of some
of my headphone cases that I have for
size comparison to the iPhone it's
pretty small I mean this thing is so
tiny
this turns into a Wi-Fi hotspot so it's
the first time that you're using this
there will be a Wi-Fi if you need to
connect you on the box and on the drone
itself it has the Wi-Fi network and the
password so once you enter that and
connect to it it will show up and then
open up the app and that will allow you
to enter into the device as you see here
this is city road see here you have your
controls depending upon how you have
your joystick set up this will raise it
up this will raise it down this is your
direction joystick so one of the coolest
things that I found is this little
switch right here so when you hit this
little button so that will allow you to
move the camera up and the camera down
oh no it wasn't you to take off should I
[Music]
Oh
it's alright my office oh boy
and there I told our snow that's what
the lawsuit was a wall
[Music]
and that's the DGI sport let's check out
some of the footage to a gel shop
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try the plum landing
it's not it's absolutely crazy